[Applaudissements]
thierry bon elle est outrancière
mais elle a toujours un avis elle est
toujours là pour les amis elle a sauté
une carapace en béton pour toutes les
attaques qui viennent de l'extérieur
elle est un peu dissipée n est ce pas
différer laisse pas indifférent elle est
clivante décomplexée et jolie il est
donc alors moi pour pour susciter un peu
l'amitié qu'elle a pour ses amis je
voulais juste montrer une photo que
personne n'a vu parce que c'est pas
passer à l'antenne pendant le prime de
tpm paix où j'étais quand même un tas
nas 2000 avant mon truc mais est elle
vous prend dans les bras et voilà elle
pense à vous et tripoter les mecs
à mon avis elle voulait sentir votre
tracteur scheiwe peut-être je n'ai pas
d'acheteur chef sait qu'on part en veut
pas rigoler avec le gars
alors il aura les larmes aux yeux un
grand un ça va
voulez vous mettre un peu de céline dion
convoqué le maire rappelle céline dion
accident
je le cherche j'irai chercher un arbre
s'est passé à nos paroles
combien la note l'a8 merci tu 8 bravo
bonne note pour et noir alors là
un mouchoir et l'otem demande on dirait
qu'on n'est pas des missions se voit
tapas mouchoirs est la paix excuse moi
tu as pas une clope 1 j'ai rien j'ai pas
de mouchoir s est pas ayrault s'est pas
laissée pas de progrès ici là